today on the matt walsh show the jesse
smilette trial has reached its dramatic
conclusion today we'll talk we'll take a
look back at this whole bizarre story
and figure out what we might learn from
it also bill de blasio defends his new
dystopian covet measures on the basis
that if new yorkers submit to this one
last infringement on their liberty covid
will be gone forever he says and the
trial of kim potter the officer who shot
dante wright begins this week right has
been mated to another martyr of the blm
cause but we'll look at the real man in
his brutal and violent history you
haven't heard some of this before it's
pretty shocking and dallas police brag
about taking a thousand rather 100 000
from someone who did not commit any
crime at all they just confiscated the
money and that was it it's called civil
asset forfeiture and it's the subject of
our cancellation today all of that and
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our word from expressvpn you know using
the internet without expressvpn it's
like leaving your laptop exposed to the
coffee table or at the coffee shop while
you run to the bathroom or you know
leaving it somewhere when you when
you're at the airport you leave your
bags out there which people do that a
lot you shouldn't do it people do that
to me they'll say can you can you watch
my stuff while i run to the bathroom
well how do you know how do you know you
can trust me do i look like the kind of
person you can trust
you shouldn't do that and uh but that's
exactly what it's like when you when you
use the internet without an expressvpn
every time you connect to an unencrypted
network cafes hotels airports any hacker
on the same network they can gain access
to your personal data that's passwords
financial details anything it doesn't
take much technical knowledge to hack
someone just some cheap hardware is
needed a smart 12 year old could do it
your data is valuable hackers can make
up to a thousand dollars per person
selling personal info on the dark web
and so why do you use expressvpn well
because it creates an encrypted tunnel
what does that mean it means it creates
a secure encrypted tunnel between your
device and the internet hackers are not
able to steal your sense of data that
way it'd take a hacker with a super
computer over a billion years to get
past
expressvpn's encryption and i think we
could safely bet that they don't have
that kind of capacity so secure your
online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com
walsh that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
walsh and you get an extra three months
for free expressvpn.comwalsh
as the jesse smellette trial comes to a
close today a spectacle that tragically
was not filmed for our amusement
it might be worthwhile to step back and
consider what we might learn from this
bizarre circus freak show to do that
we should start at the beginning all the
way back to the freezing night in
chicago in january of 2019 back in more
innocent times with the only people
wearing masks in chicago or criminals
still a lot of them are criminals but
there's also people who aren't it was
also a time according to smilet
when a man might decide to walk out of
his apartment at 2am through the pitch
black and the frigidaire to purchase a
subway sandwich on the way back from
this peculiar journey smilet says that
he was assaulted by two white men well
he initially said white men and then he
said that they weren't white but pale
turns out they were nigerian neither
white nor pale and that these pale white
trump-supporting nigerians noticed him
in the dark and pinned him as the guy
from empire a show that no trump voter
has ever seen
infamously they shouted this is magga
country and began assaulting him while
screaming racial slurs but the assault
lasted 30 seconds and left no injuries
except for a gentle bruise on his cheek
and at some point during this attack a
rope was placed around his neck and
bleach was poured on his clothes because
the trump-supporting white nigerians
were hanging around outside at night in
january in chicago with a random bottle
of bleach and a noose just in case an
actor from empire happened to be making
a run to subway for a tuna sandwich i
mean it makes perfect sense
smollett called the police
not right away but sometime later and
when he was back at his apartment
and he still had the rope around his
neck
we never found out if he ate the tuna
sandwich or not
this story was of course obviously fake
from the start occam's razor would have
us select the explanation which requires
the fewest assumptions
with the smolette story there were two
explanations one is that he was telling
the truth and the other that he was
lying
the truth explanation requires the
assumption that
racist magga trumpsters live in chicago
and they hang out on street corners at 2
a.m and they have bleach on standby just
in case
and they would recognize an actor from a
show they certainly don't watch and so
on
the lying explanation requires just one
assumption which isn't really an
assumption so much as a very reasonable
conclusion
is it more likely that all of those
implausible scenarios converged
or that jesse smellet simply told a lie
logic and common sense would seem to
guide you to the latter conclusion
and yet we can't forget that the entire
corporate media
that entire organism
rallied around smolette as did the
entire democrat party
were they stupid enough to be fooled by
the most far-fetched race hoax of the
century
i think the leftist in the peanut
gallery you know really really might
have been
the the viewers of corporate media the
democrat voters
they have to keep in mind that as i've
said recently we live in a curated
reality corporate media are reality
curators and if you rely on them for
your information and even if you don't
consciously rely on them still your
impression of the world and your access
to it is mediated by this entity which
will only show you pieces that fit
within a certain narrative framework
the effect is that many americans live
in a world or think they live in a world
where it is actually not implausible
that a hollywood celebrity might be
assaulted by a roving gang of white
supremacist trump supporters who were
lying in weight on the streets of
chicago with a bottle of bleach and a
noose at 2 am
they have bought into their curated
reality their matrix to such an extent
that this totally ridiculous fable seems
not only plausible but damn near
commonplace
to them they probably think this kind of
thing happens all the time
now for the curators themselves the
media democrats like camilla harris and
so on they of course know better
i mean they have to have a grasp on the
fuller picture of reality if they're
going to decide which pieces of it to
exclude from the picture they present to
you in the public
so they knew that smollette was full of
it but his story was politically
convenient and it was good for ratings
so they played along
it was kind of a wink and a nudge
conspiracy
which is how most actual conspiracies
work in the real world
just smallett didn't didn't have to meet
with camila harris and the heads of all
the major corporate media outlets and
come to an agreement right instead he
just kind of winks to them and they all
understand and they set out to spread
this tale far and wide for mutually
beneficial reasons
what nobody expected and what i didn't
expect either
is that the police and the prosecutor in
chicago would decline to participate in
this choreographed production
usually with these hoaxes local
authorities will pretend to hunt for the
imaginary racist hate crimer and um and
when the search comes up empty because
the person they're searching for doesn't
exist they'll throw their hands up and
say oh darn you know i guess he got
away that's exactly what happened in
madison wisconsin when a woman claimed
that she was assaulted and set on fire
by a group of white supremacists while
sitting in her car at a traffic light
and her story somehow managed to be even
less plausible than smallett's and there
was even more evidence disproving it
because she was at it she was at an
intersection in the middle of a city
with security cameras all around and
they can look at the security cameras
and say like this never happened these
people don't exist
but the cops went along with the program
they pretended to search for the
invisible assailants um and waited until
everybody stopped watching them and then
they quietly closed down the
investigation and moved on
no charges were filed against the hoaxer
in that case
that's they almost never are except here
smollett was not so lucky
he was also pressing his luck quite a
bit by attacking the police
for not finding the people
the attackers that he knew didn't exist
and i think when he did that maybe
that's when uh even you know a liberal
prosecutor has to say enough is enough
and that's what landed him on trial
where yesterday he made the radically
stupid decision to take the stand in his
own defense
it might have been a desperation move by
his defense team realizing that they
have literally no defense to offer
or it may have been a decision entirely
made by the actor himself and motivated
by his own psychotic narcissism or maybe
it was a bit of both
whatever the case he sat in the hot seat
for two days
throwing out a whole deck full of victim
cards
calling upon all of his training as a
thespian and trying to bury the case
under irrelevant and pretty gross
details about bath houses and drug use
and masturbation
the major problem smallett has aside
from the glaring absurdity of the hoax
that he perpetrated is that his
accomplices the nigerian assandario
brothers
have long since admitted that he paid
them to beat him up so that he could
pretend it was a hate crime
they even have the check he gave them
for their hate crime services
that puts millett in the position of
having to provide some reason
why his friends one of whom he said he
had a sexual relationship with would
hide out on a street corner and beat him
up while screaming anti-black slurs
his theory that he's
given is that maybe they wanted him to
hire them as bodyguards and this was
their way of convincing him
even though he was already paying them
money
for other services uh he he said well
maybe they wanted to be a bodyguard and
that's that's why they staged this whole
thing
i guess it's kind of like your mechanic
cutting your brake lines so that you'll
come back for more repairs in the very
near future
that's the theory he presented anyway
but the real point
smollett was trying to make on the stand
and the reason he took the stand to
begin with
the reason he took this this to trial
rather than accepting a plea bargain and
putting an end to this spectacle before
it began i mean he could have taken a
plea deal at any point and he wasn't
going to go to jail
but the reason he didn't do that is that
he is a gay black man and thus a victim
in general even if he wasn't a victim of
a hate crime that night
smilet knows that his identity affords
him privileges
and now he's trying to cash in those
chips
that is that's the wager that he's
making
and this really came through one during
one interesting exchange between the
prosecutor and smollette the daily mail
has details it says smolette uh also
became defensive when asked why he sent
instagram private messages to abel
ascendario
in the hours before the attack with
prosecutors suggesting that he was
filling him in on the fact that his
flight from new york to chicago was
delayed which would delay the plan
and that's by the way that's that's a
detail i i don't think we knew until
this time but he um he actually he he
flew from new york to chicago to to have
this fake hate crime perpetrated against
him
anyway um he then the messages said uh
n n word he wrote it out this is brutal
still on this damn runway
um
and then another one said
n
finally made it
in the messages millet repeatedly used
the n-word but on tuesday he told webb
the prosecutor
not to read not to say the n-word while
reading the text out loud out of respect
for quote every african-american person
in the room
webb who is white apologized and smilet
quipped apology accepted but it's been
used a lot
yeah it's been used a lot because you
used it and they're reading your
messages
so the prosecutor reads molet's text
messages back to him verbatim but
smellette scolded him for reading his
own words
smilet's privilege as a black man is
such that he has permitted access to
certain language that the prosecutor a
white man cannot use even while quoting
smilet himself in a courtroom where
precision and specificity of language is
important
why did the prosecutor say the whole
word word rather than saying the n-word
well because he was quoting and the
person that he was quoting smilet didn't
say the n-word he said the word
also we all know the word and we've
heard it many times almost always from
people who look like smolette and not
the prosecutor
what exact damage is done by hearing it
in this context
the word is given you know this mystical
power
it is the only combination of syllables
in the english language or any other
language which is considered
outrageously offensive no matter the
context depending on the skin
pigmentation of the person saying it
it's the only word in existence in any
language
or where one person with a certain skin
color can say it to you but you are not
allowed to say it even when quoting what
they just said
and not only that
but the person who said it
can claim to be offended by his own
words when they come out of your
mouth but this again speaks to privilege
and that's what the story is really
about
it's a story a story of privilege true
privilege
is how privilege works in america today
i mean smallette was a man drunk on his
own privilege
and desperate for more
and these are the lengths
to which you will go
now we'll see if he'll pay the price for
that
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well if you're feeling miserable in your
day-to-day life i can't solve most of
that for you there's a lot there's a lot
underpinning it but i tell you one one
reason might be that you're not getting
enough sleep and lots of us are not
getting enough sleep and uh maybe
because you don't have the right kind of
mattress if you're sleeping on some
old sagging mattress at night then you
deserve better than that you need better
than that and that's why you need helix
sleep helix sleep has a quiz that takes
just two minutes to complete and it
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you if you like a mattress that's really
soft or firm if you sleep on your side
or your back whatever it is with helix
there's a specific mattress for each and
everybody's unique tastes you don't need
to take their word for it helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress of 2019 and 2020 by gq and
wired magazine just go to helixsleep.com
walls take their two minute sleep quiz
and they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your night guaranteed
and right now helix is offering up to
200 off and free pillows with all
mattress orders for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
walsh that's helixsleep.comwalsh for up
to 200 off your mattress order
all right don't mind me by the way i was
just drinking from my uh wonderful uh
sweet baby gang coffee mug here which
you can get at the dailywire.com shop if
you go to my shop this is this is a this
is a high quality mug i have to say uh
the other great thing is uh you know if
you
for those of you who who are who have
certain bigotries and you don't like the
sweet baby gang apparel and merchandise
that has me and a diaper on it uh this
one is just my face there's no diaper
there so um no you could you could buy
that that's that's if for some reason
you don't want a bearded man in a diaper
on your coffee mug you don't want people
asking questions then at least you can
get that
which which maybe that's for the best i
mean i have thought about the fact that
um
i'm gonna have to live with this for the
rest of my life uh especially because
we've sold so many of those damn
t-shirts we sold like a million of them
maybe not a million but it seems like it
and so they're everywhere and for the
rest of my life
as my kids grow older
they're going to see these kinds of
images and start asking questions
and i'll i'll have to live with that but
you know what i'm i i commit myself to
that into that life of shame for the
sake of the sweet baby game
um all right we'll start here bill de
blasio is still out defending his
dystopian covet policies
and uh the the especially the newest
policy that he just put in place well he
put two things in place we talked about
yesterday one was
a
vaccine mandate for um for employers
so you're not allowed to have a job in
new york if you don't get the vaccine
and then the other one most egregiously
is a vaccine mandate for children not
just a mandate but uh a segregation
policy now for children
a kind of apartheid system put in place
where children are affected and if a
child at the age of five or or between
five and eleven doesn't have the vaccine
and cannot produce his papers to prove
he had a vaccine then the child can be
kicked out of public accommodations
restaurants movie theaters so on and so
forth uh of course schools
sports leagues everything else
so bill de blasio's explaining this and
defending it but the worst thing is what
he says at the very end of this clip
listen
here in new york city we were the
epicenter of the covet crisis we lost so
many people in this neighborhood david's
all over the city
we didn't have ppe we didn't have
ventilators we were alone
and then we started to fight back and
vaccines came and we focused on
vaccination it made all the difference
we're now the safest place in this
country we've got to go even farther
omicron's here winter's coming we gotta
go even farther today in new york city
we announced a mandate all private
sector employers
must have their employees vaccinated by
december 27th this is what's going to
keep us safe this is the kind of thing
we need to do now not just here but
everywhere so we can leave kobe behind
once and for all
leave covent behind once and for all he
says he is still pushing that he is
still
that's that's still the carrot on the
end of the stick that he's that he's uh
presenting to people
that
we've been hearing this for two years
from people like bill de blasio
he's probably used that exact phrase 50
other times
just this one more thing
a little bit more of your liberties and
your freedoms and your and even more
than that your dignity as a human being
um
sacrifice a little bit more of that
and we can leave cove behind once and
for all
and and allow us to do this to your
children now
and uh and soon there will be no covet
and people in new york will allow it
i'm not saying that everybody in new
york is happy about this or necessarily
goes along with it but
the the little bit of time which was too
much time that i spent in new york a
month ago two months ago
and before these uh these latest
policies were put in place
it's it's it's very disturbing and
depressing to see that most people
just go along with it don't question it
don't argue it
okay few and far between are the people
who
register any protest at all
and that's the kind of the dirty little
secret here is that
not only the reason why bill de blasio
gets away with this kind of thing
is that not only are most people in the
city willing to go along with it but um
but they they want it
they want this
they want to sacrifice their freedom and
liberty and their dignity
on the altar of safety it makes them
feel better
it makes them feel like they're doing
something
and it's also it's also a giant virtue
signal
this is a virtue signal now on the left
is to submit yourself to tyranny
submit yourself to it and then you're
showing off
your view your your virtue and how much
you care about safety how much you care
about others
unlike those you know
those riff-raff who talk about their
freedoms and their rights yuck
so that's the worst part about it there
have always been tyrannical politicians
there always will be
uh power positions of power attract
those types of people
by their nature
those kinds of people are always go the
megalomaniacs like like bill de blasio
especially talentless megalomaniacs who
can't do anything else
they can't go into any other line of
work and find the power that they crave
because that would require them to have
skills and you don't necessarily have to
have any skills at all to be a
politician
so
positions of power have always attracted
people like bill de blasio
the problem though
in these cities and why these cities are
falling apart
it's it's not even just the politicians
it's easy to blame the politicians but
really it goes down to the people
if the people said we're no we're not
going to do this
there's a really easy way around this
vex this mandate for five to 11 year
olds
it's for the people of new york to say
hell no you are not kicking my
five-year-old out of anywhere because
they don't show their papers i refuse to
go along with it we're not doing that
no that we're not playing that game now
you're coming for my kids
i draw a line there and if every single
even if even 50 if even 20 of them said
that
then this policy would go away because
what's the other option they're gonna
start locking all these parents in
prison
do they really want does does bill de
blasio want the spectacle
of um of dragging like
imagine what that's gonna look
like what's it gonna look like in
practice
the first time a six-year-old goes to i
don't know chuck e cheese for his
birthday
and is told you have to show me your
papers oh we don't have it get
out does uh does does de blasio does he
want that spectacle
um
i don't think he does and so it wouldn't
take much of that
it wouldn't take very many incidents of
that type to make this go away
but he's wait he's betting on the fact
that uh most most parents will just you
know they won't even put
they won't create situations like that
they're going to go and get their kid
vaccinated obediently as they've been
told even if covet poses no serious risk
to their kids statistically they're
gonna go get the cova vaccine anyway
and if for whatever reason their kid
doesn't have a vaccine they're just
gonna they're gonna do as they're told
they're gonna keep their kid out of
these environments
and they're not going to cause any
trouble
this the the whole thing that we used to
i used to hear about uh all the time
about new yorkers growing up is that new
yorkers but they're they're a headstrong
bunch
you don't mess you don't mess with those
tough new yorkers that is out the window
i used to think the same thing about
australians
i was totally wrong on that one too
there was probably a time when it was
true i used to think you live down in
australia there's spiders the size of
buicks walking around crawling
everywhere everything is deadly
everything's going to kill you uh you
got you got to be a tops tough son of a
[ __ ] to live in uh to live in australia
and maybe one time that was true uh just
like maybe one time it was true in new
york but it's not true anymore
these are
cowed
submissive people who have given into
this
and if you give in to it where your
children are concerned then i don't know
what to say shame on you you're no
american
i don't want to i don't i don't want to
share a country with you
i want to share anything with you
very easy to make this go away if you
don't want it
just say no
like we've been saying our motto here do
not comply say no continue on your life
make them drag you out
make them drag your children out
make them do that call their bluff
um
and then the other thing though he says
uh going back to it the the whole uh
we can leave covert behind once and for
all
once again that is not going to happen
that's a fantasy if you're still
believing that then you are you
you have been fooled
you're probably beyond saving at this
point if you're that stupid that you
still think that just
one more thing one put one more policy
in place and we'll be covetable behind
us be behind us once and for all no it
won't be
you don't need to be a scientist to see
it now covet is everywhere it's spread
across the entire globe
hundreds of millions billions of people
have have uh come in contact with it
you're not going to escape it
you're going to come in contact with it
it's going to be with you for the rest
of your life it is going to be a part of
the environment now that you live in
i don't like it it's not a good
not anything to celebrate
but it is just one more risk that exists
out there in the world among many
and as i've been trying to remind people
for two years now
and it it may sound scary but it's true
and there's also a certain
liberation that comes in confronting
this and realizing that of all those
threats out there in the world
most of them
will never harm you
but
some of them will
and one day one of them is going to kill
you one of those threats
the the cause of your death
exists out there right now
and uh there's no telling what it will
be but it will be something
and so the decision you have to make is
whether you are going to live your life
in the meantime while you can before you
inevitably die
or if in the name of preserving your
life you're going to forfeit your life
ahead of time almost as a preemptive
strike against death
but you're saying to death ah you can't
take life for me i've already given it
up
it's kind of a you can't fire me i quit
mentality that people are taking now
it's pathetic
worst empathetic okay this is from the
uh let's see okay we'll start here the
trial of kim potter began this week this
she's the minnesota police officer who
shot dante wright during a traffic stop
now fox news has some information about
dante right some of the background on
this guy
and i knew some of this some of it i've
i've previously reported on this show
you've heard it before but there are
other details that had escaped my notice
until now and escaped i think most
people's notice
and that's all by design from our
reality curators and this was not part
of the reality they told us about so
let me read this from fox and it says
justice for dante wright reads a marquee
at um minneapolis george floyd square
towering over what used to be a gas
station across the street from where
derek chauvin knelt on george floyd's
neck on memorial day 2020. at the
fortified police station brooklyn center
someone installed letters to spell out
dante wright in all caps on a barricade
erected around the perimeter and
prominent civil rights attorney ben
crump is representing the slain 20 year
old's family following his shooting
death
at the hands of former police officer
kim potter whose trial begins on
wednesday but right before his death
left behind a trail of victims whose
lives he upended with gun violence of
his own
karma's a [ __ ]
two such women told fox news digital on
monday unprompted and in separate
interviews
the victim said that they would have
preferred right-face consequences for
his actions in a court of law while also
arguing that his own decision in
attempting to flee a lawful traffic stop
contributed in part to his shooting
death on april 11th
then we get into what what uh
what dante wright did
this as fox news was this trail of
victims he left behind
and dante wright was was only 20 years
old which makes him a grown man the left
talks about him like he was an innocent
child and as always most of the pictures
we see of him are um you know pictures
from when he was when he was in fifth
grade or something
the pictures from the from the rare
moments in his life when he was not
violently assaulting someone um
those are the pictures that we see
but he was 20 years old still pretty
young
and in that short life
the amount of violent crime he was able
to cram in his like almost impressive
so we'll read from this and also this is
really unusual
because we know that
blm martyrs
are almost always
violent criminals and scumbags
who have victimized many people in their
lives
yet we almost never hear from those
victims
and the reason is the media has no
interest in talking to them and also
they probably have very little interest
most of the time in saying anything
publicly because there's nothing in it
for them now they're just going to be
re-victimized
they were victimized once by this guy
and now the guy is dead and he's turned
into a martyr and you got to see his
damn mural in his face everywhere and if
they were to speak out again now they're
going to be victimized once more for
attacking the sainted george floyd or
whoever else
but in this case some of these victims
have actually spoken out and two of them
said
unprompted karma's a [ __ ] that's their
perspective and you can understand why
that would be their perspective
especially when you hear what this guy
did so
um
reading on it says caleb livingston was
16 years old when wright allegedly shot
him in the head at the full stop gas
station on minneapolis's lowry avenue
initially doctors told caleb's mother
that he wouldn't survive surgery after
the attack he pulled through but he
can't talk or walk
he suffers from unresponsive wakefulness
syndrome and requires around-the-clock
assistance
livingston's mother jennifer lemay says
i pray for everybody involved because
there's a loss of life
i know what right's parents are going
through because i lost my own son i
almost lost my son
now who right was before he was killed
it is what it is
in december 2019 wright and a friend
emma j driver
stayed over at a young woman's apartment
after a night of drinking and smoking
pot
the following morning after driver saw
her slip 820 into her bra
wright allegedly pulled out a handgun
choked her twice and tried to rob her
stuck his hand into her bra that's
sexual assault
after an ensuing struggle right and
driver left empty-handed unbeknownst to
the victim who believed they'd taken her
hard-earned cash until she called 9-1-1
and found it still tucked away within
her torn clothes
the survivor told fox news the person
was evil that person talking about right
was evil he didn't care about me in that
moment
video obtained exclusively by fox news
digital earlier this year shows wright
playing with a handgun in her bathroom
moments before the attempted robbery he
recorded it himself and police seized it
from his phone
um
and then we continue
let's see
there's one more
[Music]
right that alleged gang member was also
accused of waving a black handgun near a
minneapolis intersection before ditching
it and fleeing on foot eluding
responding officers when police attempt
pulled him over in april they found he
had an active warrant in that incident
and arrested him
uh attempted to arrest him
and there was also one other incident
where he's accused of um
oh here we go
there was another one a robbery and
there was a there's a few lawsuits
against wright's estate
from these victims and one is in
connection with a carjacking that left a
former classmate shot in the leg okay so
that's what we've got we've got dante
wright and his short life and these are
just the incidents we know about
uh we have him allegedly shooting
somebody in the head and leaving them
disabled for life at a gas station
we have him robbing a woman at gunpoint
after he was he was at her house and she
allowed him to stay over
invited him into his home
into her home allowed him to stay over
and the next morning he pointed a gun at
her and sexually assaulted her to try to
steal her her money that she had earned
from working and then we have another
where there's a carjacking and somebody
gets shot and then another case where
he's at an intersection waving a gun
around
so that's dante right for you
this is
this is not youthful indiscretion these
are not simply poor choices or mistakes
or anything like that
this is
abject
psychopathic evil this is someone who
has no concern for other people's lives
for their humanity
that does he doesn't recognize other
human beings as being human
and uh that's how he lived his life
is any of that relevant to
the this case and what's going on now
yeah it's relevant to for two reasons
number one as always
it's not just
that
this is going into the court system and
uh and and and people are looking for
justice that way they're going far
beyond that
they're also putting his name up in in
putting his face up in murals
and expecting us all to mourn and weep
over his lost life
treating his death and his his now
absence from the world as a national
tragedy
and because you have done that
that's where it becomes relevant for me
to bring in his past
if this was simply a court case
and we were leaving it at that
then it might it might be less relevant
but when you tell me that we're all
supposed to this is a horrible person
this guy's a scumbag well i'm supposed
to cry that that he's no longer on earth
and victimizing people shooting people
in the head sexually assaulting women at
gunpoint you want me to cry over the
fact that he's not around anymore
see when you tell me that i'm supposed
to react that way that's when it becomes
relevant for me to say well no
it's a horrible human being that the
fact that he was absolutely awful in a
scumbag doesn't necessarily mean that
his shooting was justified
but it does mean that your reaction to
this is not justified
a lot of people die every single day in
this country many of them victims of
people like dante wright and all of them
i mean if you want to look for
victims of violent crime to weep over
any of them would be more worthy
of your mourning and your sadness than
this guy
um so that's why it's relevant but it's
also relevant because
it's his his life of violent crime is
the reason why
there was a warrant for his arrest
and also his habit of doing whatever the
hell he wants and being as violent as he
wants and not facing any consequences
that is what led him to believe
that he could fight the cops and get
away and it would be okay
because when you see that you think
again this is a grown man
it might be a young man but he's a grown
man
and you think what the hell is your plan
here
there's a warrant for your arrest they
know who you are you're in town
so you're going to fight the cops and
drive away and then what
you think they're just going to say well
never mind
uh he got away fair fair let him go i
mean we might be getting to the point
where they start saying that but but at
that point that's not the way the cops
operated
so now you're just adding another charge
that's all you're doing they're still
going to get you
unless you are
some sort of
expert global assassin type criminal and
you've got you know you've got your go
bag all ready and you've got contacts in
other countries and you're ready with a
new social security number a new you're
ready with a you know to change your
name and everything flee the flee the
country start a new life
maybe then you'll get away but i doubt
that was the case for dante wright
he wasn't going to go anywhere he was
just going to run away and eventually
they'd catch him and
now he's going to go to prison for even
longer so you see they think well why
would you respond that way
they have you dead to rights you want it
you're you're wanted on an arrest
warrant
um there's nothing to be gained from
struggling and trying to well the answer
is that
he had grown accustomed i mean he had
committed all these crimes allegedly and
um and he was still walking around free
so he thought well this i can do this
and so that contributed to his his
response
and so yeah i do think that his
uh the way that he lived his life and
his history very very relevant
um
all right
you know so we'll take a look at this
you know how i feel about knocking down
statues uh i've you know that i'm very
much against it i as i've said before
um
this the war on history of going through
the the country
going across the land and tearing down
all of these supposedly offensive
statues very much opposed to it
and
even if you find a statue
where there may be an argument
that it should be taken down because
it's offensive in some way i mean there
are there might be statues out there
like that
but you should still oppose taking the
statues down
right now
in response to the mob
okay if we're taking down a statue it
should be a thoughtful considered
decision and it should never be
in response to or
in submission to a mob
so that's been my position my position
but there are exceptions to every rule
we know that so here is one exception
uh we have nashville scene on twitter
they uh report the nathan bedford forest
nathan bedford forest has followed a
widely mocked
nashville statue of the early kkk leader
was removed tuesday morning
um and this was uh right here in
nashville i've driven by this thing i've
seen it before
and when you look at a zoom in on this
statue i'll tell you this is why i i
make an exception here and i'm and i'm
happy this one was taken down
simply because it is the ugliest statue
i've ever seen in my life i've driven by
this thing and i've seen it and i've
been perplexed by it i honestly thought
at first that it was put there to make
fun of nathan bedford first i thought
this was kind of it was meant to be a
mockery
he looks like something from you know
like he looks like a nutcracker or
something or maybe a combination of a
nutcracker maybe uh maybe
a combination of
goofy
with a civil war if if maybe there's a
mickey mouse club
civil war episode
and goofy was a confederate general he
would look like this statue
is the ugliest most gaudy hideous statue
i've ever seen in my life and it's
offensive putting everything else aside
it's a it's it is a it's offensive
aesthetically
and so i'm fine with that
i think that is the number one if you're
tearing down a statue
that should be the number one reason to
do it
the the number one offense
that a statue can commit is that it is
ugly it's ugly it's supposed to be a
piece of art and if the art is that we
talk about the uglification of uh
of our country yesterday
and ugly things are offensive in a very
real sense
and so this as a hideous ugly statue
deserves to be torn down so i'm fine
with that that one i will allow
um i'm glad that's been taken down my
only fear now is that in its place we're
going to get an equally ugly
statue or modern art sculpture of some
kind or maybe there'll be a 50-foot
you know
monument to george floyd or something
that's my only fear
i'd prefer just take that thing down
it's it's hideous it's ugly
grow some trees in its place and we'll
just move on with our lives um so i'm
fine with that i am not so fine with
this this is from the new york times it
says the city council of charlottesville
virginia voted on tuesday to donate a
statue of robert e lee to an
african-american heritage center that
plans to melt the bronze monument the
focus of a deadly white nationalist
rally in 2017 into material for a new
piece of public art
the 4-0 vote by the council followed
years of debate over the fate of the
statue four years ago a plan to remove
the statue drew scores of white
nationalists to charlottesville for
unite the right rally um
and the new york times continues after
taking it down the city accepted
proposals from bidders who wanted the
lee statue and a nearby statue of
stonewall jackson another confederate
general that was also removed the
statuary park at gettysburg in
pennsylvania asked for both
saying in his proposal that i wanted to
rescue unwanted statues associated with
the civil war well that okay there is
one destination that would make a lot of
sense i'm not in favor of tearing most
of these statues down but once you've
done that and you have now this um
these beautiful statues now that robert
e lee statue is also an equest
equestrian statue um but that's the
opposite of this one in many ways
because that's actually a beautiful work
of art
and that is one of the things that makes
our
campaign of tearing down statues so
tragic is that we are destroying and
discarding beautiful works of art many
of which have stood there for a century
or more
um
another aspect of the war on beauty
but what we were told is that well we're
not no we're not destroying it we are
simply relocating it putting it in a
different place and if you're going to
relocate it
gettysburg seems like a great place to
put it
but we continue here
uh lacs art a los angeles-based visual
arts organization wanted both statues
for a planned exhibition
um
and uh
so there was there were
people
bidding on this thing saying that they
wanted the statue and uh various i think
gettysburg made the most sense they have
a sense they have a statuary park why
not give it to them and you can put it
there with all the other uh civil war
monuments and if you've never been to
gettysburg before it's worth the trip
sometime if you're anywhere anywhere
close by um i've been to gettysburg many
times and there there are very there are
many
civil war monuments and statues and
everything of course because it's
gettysburg
uh but they decided no we're not gonna
send it to statuary park at gettysburg
we're not gonna send it for any art
exhibit or anything like that uh instead
we're gonna send it to the
african american
center and they're going to melt it down
and destroy it
so everything that you heard
about this is not a war on history
this isn't a this isn't a war on history
we're we're sending it to a museum and
museums are places
for history so this is the opposite of a
world history we're just taking these
things and putting them in there in
their rightful place
if you bought that
then
here you go this was always going to be
the case it was never going to a museum
now we're going to melt it down
you know they're going to they're going
to
make a bust of dante wright instead or
something like that
it's this almost religious kind of
ritual
this is an excising the way that they
look at it on the left is that this is
an excising this is an exorcism
of america's sins
there's a religious spiritual
significance to it
and so as part of the exorcism you're
not going to take this possessed
offending object and put it in a museum
no you're going to destroy it
and then make make something else out of
it something that is certain to be far
uglier than uh
what was there before we all have that
one relative especially as people get
older they have trouble hearing and so
you have to repeat the same thing over
and over to that over and over again to
them do them a favor this christmas and
tell them to check out md hearing aid
that's why uh you've really got to check
out md hearing aid md hearing aid is an
fda registered rechargeable hearing aid
that costs a fraction of what typical
hearing aids cost the average price of a
hearing aid in america is over 2 400 a
pair but their vault plus model is just
299 dollars each when you buy a pair so
that's the kind of savings you get md
hearing aid was founded by an ent
surgeon who saw how many of his patients
needed hearing aids but could not afford
them he made it his mission to develop a
quality hearing aid that anybody can
afford their sleek design fits so well
nobody will even know that you're
wearing it they're rechargeable and they
even have models that are water
resistant as well you don't even need a
prescription or a doctor's appointment
for this you buy it directly from them
with audiologists and licensed hearing
specialists available seven days a week
they've got six hundred thousand
satisfied customers you can be the next
one you've gotta take advantage of this
it's time to reclaim your life from
hearing loss go to mdhearingaid.com and
use promo code walls to get their buy
one get one free deal plus they are
adding a free extra charging case a 100
value for just for just for our
listeners of the matt wall show so head
to mdhearingaid.com use our promo code
walsh or you can call them at
1-833-637-1024 that's 1-833-637-1024
[Music]
uh let's see gianna says i'm convinced
that the person at amazon who put your
book in the lgbt section is an
undercover member of the sweet baby gang
just doing his duty well we are
everywhere maybe we're even at amazon i
don't know we'll find out
mary b says matt you'd be surprised by
how many people want to see you do
modeling shots i'm a woman so it's not
weird for me to point it out hopefully
i'm not canceled
okay well i guess we'll start working on
the calendar now that'll be our next
thing at the
at the swag shack dailywire.com shop
we'll have a
we'll have my modeling calendar
and every single
month will just be me staring blankly
expressionless into the camera
um
a confused walrus great name says walrus
awareness week is our holiest of weeks
how dare you fat shame my people during
this time of year i a gay transgender
walrus cancel you matt you're a band
from the show i didn't what are you
talking about confused walrus i did the
exact opposite i was defending the
walrus community against the fat shaming
that was was happening i mean it's
walrus awareness week of all of all
times of all the times to body shame
walrus to do it during walrus awareness
week is unconscionable
and i was defending the community
against those sorts of attacks i don't
know what you were listening i don't
know what show you were listening to not
this one
not one hosted by the author of johnny
the walrus which is available now at
johnnywalders.com
uh packcast says when is matt going to
cancel nfts i heard that's all the rage
with the millennials and uh generation
z's nowadays
uh yeah well i would cancel them if i
had any idea what they were if i
understood it all what they were
from
for i mean they're basically it's it's
kind of like with the bitcoin i said
bitcoins it's like they're like beanie
babies or something collectibles
uh that's what an nft is two base
essentially right it's a digital beanie
baby
and you buy this did like a collection
of pixels that you buy and then you keep
it somewhere in
cyberspace and you spend a lot of money
on it
i don't even understand what it is i'm
sure that it's stupid though whatever it
is
i guess you're right there's no reason
why i should have to understand
something before canceling it i've never
operated that way before and why should
i start now
um
and uh let's see
a lot says the bench is la banca not
banco banco is a bank as in saving money
okay well i told you i didn't know
spanish i knew before i
before i i tried to do a little bit of
spanish in the opening monologue
yesterday to make a point i knew it was
a mistake
and what i should have done is just
googled it but i was too lazy and so
that's what i ended up doing but perfect
example i mean bonco is a bank that's a
noun it's a masculine
you know it's a masculine noun
so i guess that's a that's another one
if we're going to make the entire
language gender neutral then it would
have to be
um
bonkers
just put the x at the end you you step
you take you take the vowel out you put
an x in and that's how you make
everything gender-neutral so the spanish
language is about to become very very
confusing i think last week you know
biden announced his winter covid plan
not only did biden announce that he is
extending the federal mass mandate for
public transportation but the
administration is actually considering
requiring americans to be fully
vaccinated in order to fly domestically
as well so if you want to
visit your family over the holidays you
may need to drive across the country
rather than getting on a plane
or you'll have to comply the obama
administration is working overtime to
force you to do the ladder to comply
that's why we filed a lawsuit against
biden's vaccine mandate for private
employers the government does not get to
make our private medical choices for us
or dictate how we live that's not how
it's supposed to work in america but we
need your help if you haven't signed our
petition against biden's vaccine mandate
yet i need you to head on over to
dailywire.com
do not comply we have over 700 000
signatures we want to get to a million
signatures that's when it really is
something that that they have to take
note of so go to dailywire.com do not
comply and sign that petition and also
um
johnnywalrus at what's upside down john
the walrus johnnywalrus.com
if you want to buy the book that is the
literary sensation of the year and uh
that it was written by the leading lgbt
voice then this is your opportunity to
do it uh we've been in the top 10 on
amazon you know
what we sold out we were top ten we sold
out then we got more copies and we sold
out and we were we're top 10 on amazon
again um but we want to get it all the
way to number one because why for a lot
of reasons but as i've been saying
that's also just the funniest thing
that's that's the funniest conclusion of
this sagas to be number one overall in
amazon so help us get there go to
johnnywalrus.com now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel the dallas police
department for proudly bragging about
committing felony theft well it would be
felony theft if agents of the state were
subject to the same laws as the rest of
us as it happens they are not which led
to the to this post from dallas pd on
facebook
showing a police dog named ballentine
standing near a massive pile of
cash hundred thousand 000 to be exact
and the caption of the post says
we need to get him some treats canine
officer valentine does it again on
december 2 2021 the love field
interdiction squad seized over a hundred
thousand dollars with the help of
ballentine good job valentine this
certainly does nothing to just dissuade
my prejudice against dogs by the way
this is why cats i don't like cats but
they are superior in the end
because at least they aren't narcs they
aren't tattletails like a cat's gonna
mind their own business they see what
you're up to and they're gonna to say
you know do your thing i'm doing my
thing
the dog's going to go tell on you
now you might be wondering about the
rest of the story what crime did this
person commit
well this person a woman
didn't commit any crime nor was she
charged with or accused of any crime
what she did was fly from chicago to
dallas with a lot of money in her
luggage it is not illegal to have your
own money in your luggage by the way
that is not illegal
and yet through a little magic called
civil asset forfeiture the police can
seize your money along with any other
property it wants
without charging you with a crime
without giving you recourse to any sort
of due process
they simply take the money and that's it
this is ours now they say thank you for
your contribution
civil asset forfeiture is extremely
common and it's big business for the
state ostensibly they steal the money
because it might be connected to a crime
the problem is they don't have to prove
that it was connected to a crime or even
officially accuse you or charge you with
the crime
they can still take it and they can keep
it how do you get it back well in
practice you don't
few people ever do due process is
flipped on its head in a civil asset
forfeiture case now the person whose
property was seized must prove that they
were not committing a crime
they must prove a negative
if they can't they're out of luck
you also
don't have the right to counsel in these
cases so if you don't have the time and
money to fight it which most people
don't then you're even more out of luck
and if you really want to fight it out
then you better be ready for the long
haul a guy named jerry johnson flew from
north carolina to phoenix to buy a truck
for his small business last year
uh he was paying in cash about 40
thousand dollars and he brought it with
him rather than trying to withdraw the
some out of state
police at the airport took all of the
money claiming it was for drugs
but they didn't charge him with with a
drug trafficking crime because there was
no evidence of it
johnson produced documents proving that
he was trying to buy a truck but the
court said that his evidence of
innocence was insufficient
a year later in the case is just now
going to an appeals court
we should also note that in most cases
police aren't seizing massive amounts of
money
i mean they aren't even trying to take
down pablo escobar types drug kingpins
which which again ostensibly is what
what these laws are supposed to be on
the books for instead on average they
confiscate a few hundred dollars at a
time in my state tennessee the average
hall is about 500 bucks
this means that the theft victim has
little incentive to go through the
bureaucratic hell to get their property
back
they'll probably lose more in the
attempted recovery than they lost in the
initial burglary
this is all as i said big business for
the government at the federal level the
justice department has massively
increased its revenue through civil
forfeitures on the local level in many
states police get to keep a hundred
percent of what they take
no conflict of interest there right
altogether the government makes billions
and billions of dollars this way
just by taking it from citizens
and that explains why there is not a
bipartisan effort to repeal these laws
on the federal level an effort that
would be extremely popular on the right
and left among almost all voters
but money is king and the government
makes a lot of money by stealing it
why would it ever give that up
money certainly trumps the constitution
which explicitly and unambiguously
forbids exactly this sort of thing you
are guaranteed the right to be free from
the seizure of property without due
process it's right there in the fifth
amendment you can look it up for
yourself in fact i'll read it for you
verbatim no person shall be deprived of
life liberty or property without due
process of law nor shall private
property be taken for public use without
just compensation
civil asset forfeiture defies every
aspect of this clause your property is
taken with no due process and you're not
compensated
it would seem that this amendment must
be changed to read no person shall be
deprived of property without due process
unless the government really really
wants to and promises they have a good
reason in which case okay fine
keep in mind as i said that there is
bipartisan support for this system from
both parties going all the way to the
top as journalist chuck modi on twitter
pointed out a very prominent politician
was a huge proponent of state-sponsored
theft for years now and and was one of
the leading figures responsible for
codifying this into law in the name of
fighting quote the war on drugs you may
recognize this guy let's watch
we changed the law so that if you are
arrested and you are a drug dealer under
our forfeiture statutes
you can the government can take
everything you own
everything from your car to your house
your bank account not merely what they
confiscate in terms of the dollars from
the transaction that you just got caught
engaging in they can take everything
we have laws in the last several years
where we don't allow judges discretion
to sentence people
flat time sentencing
you get caught you go to jail
well
all of these tools have been at the
president's disposal for the last
hundred weeks
and more
now if america's crime problem is worse
than it ever was it's not because the
congress has failed to give the
president the tools
it's done its part but rather because
the administration has failed to use the
power given to it by the congress over
the last five years and in particular
the last 100 weeks to bring this
epidemic under control
now he meant all of that in a good way
just to clarify he was talking about the
government taking all of your stuff and
doing whatever it wants and expect us to
be grateful for it
in fact his gripe at the time was that
the these laws weren't being being
utilized enough and not enough private
property had been unconstitutionally
confiscated
how did that all work out by the way
biden america's crime problem was worse
than it ever was in 1991 biden says then
we put all these policies in place
how are we doing now vis-a-vis the crime
problem
not too great from what i understand in
fact crime today especially violent
crime is worse than it ever was
it would seem that simply empowering the
government to engage in armed robbery
isn't a great strategy for crime
reduction
at best you are shifting the crime from
private citizens to the government
it's a kind of nationalization of theft
though you may argue that the irs
already did that
what we confront with civil asset
forfeiture is the harsh reality that the
constitution is a piece of paper
an artifact really speaking of things in
museums not a divinely self-enforcing
edict
the constitution has no power on its own
no law ever does or can it derives its
power from the respect and deference
paid to it by the human beings who run
the country but the human beings who run
our country right now have no respect or
deference for it or for any other law or
any other standard beyond their own
whims
we become then a fundamentally lawless
country because there is nothing
underpinning the actions of the state
other than the arbitrary self-serving
impulses of the individuals who comprise
it civil asset forfeiture is not the
cause of this situation or even
necessarily the worst example of it but
uh that is the situation nonetheless
and that is why today not only the
dallas police department but civil asset
forfeiture is also canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
82 of democrats are willing to wear
masks indoors at all times chris cuomo
gets ready to sue cnn and aoc tells
looted store owners not to believe their
own lying eyes check it out on the
michael knowles show